concern this evening from some ccsd
parents over their child's access or
lack thereof to their cell phones in
class it's a new policy set in place for
the upcoming school year by the district
for security that's right jeremy j ford
paid a visit to several schools today
and spoke with some parents about how
these changes are affecting the children
and now
we have no way of getting through that's
that's alarming to me diba saparito has
a son who attends las vegas academy
which requires students to put cell
phones in a pouch at each classroom door
and she's afraid that makes it more
difficult to get in touch with her son
if she needs to if there's an emergency
a family emergency i want to be able to
let him know or if i can't make it on
time
i'm not able to let him know ccsd only
permits students to use cell phones
during lunch and school sponsored
activities and can only use phones
during class time with the principal say
so the tight rules concern saporito as a
parent i
if i need to tell him something i'd
rather you know i would text i wouldn't
interrupt his class because he always
has the phone off anyway but other
parents have a different perspective i
guess i kind of understand to keep the
children focused because she would
rather have her son learning than being
distracted i don't think it's a bad idea
i get it but at the same time with the
world that we live in today i feel like
you know something happens or whatever
they'll be able to alert the parents
jeremy j ford live local now
well we reached out to ccsd for comment
on this policy but we have not heard
back now the decision is one of several
new security policies in place this year
those include one entry point at schools
as well as a bathroom policy where
students must turn in cell phones before
using the bathroom
on twitter we asked you do you agree
with limiting cell phones in school
during classroom time and at last check
the majority of you said yes you can
keep the conversation going by weighing
in on our social media channels